so how long have you been a man again a
man in the wasp is really the next
chapter in the ant-man saga and it is
really about the search for Janet Van
Dyne the original wasp
it's also the first time we see hope Van
Dyne played by Evangeline Lilly as the
hero wasp you gave her wings and
blasters so I take it you didn't have
that tech available for me no I did it's
amazing mates we've we shot in this 65
millimeter format which is huge and
beautiful and the movie the aspect ratio
is 2 3 5
but for IMAX we specifically designed
large chunks of the movie to be in the
one nine aspect ratio for IMAX but it
looks incredible I mean it really puts
you in the movie for for all of it for
the for the ant-man stuff for the wasp
and for giant man it really is you know
you just get them you get into so much
more picture and it's it's incredible
and the wasp teaming up no there's a
scene where um Hank Pym shrunken lab is
taken by a guy named Sonny Bert's played
Ben Walton Goggins he's hiding away on a
whale-watching boat and Damon flies out
to try and catch him a man is
temporarily foiled but then appears this
giant man the largest incarnation of
giant man and in IMAX is incredible
because it really plays the top and
bottom and you really get a sense of how
large giant man is hey what'd I miss
you